au menu du jour un feuilleté de saumon
sur son lit de fondue de poireaux la
recette est appétissante et les chefs à
l'écouté des conseils
l'enjeu est de taille qui des hommes ou
des femmes seront les meilleurs
cuisiniers
si le concours est sérieux la bonne
humeur est de mise pour cette activité
initiée par le centre social de
magny-les-hameaux objectif principal
cuire les idées reçues on est capable de
faire tous la même chose
le problème c'est que la société nous a
mis dans des cars et qu'effectivement
les hommes contrairement à la cuisine
par contre il bricole peut-être un peu
mieux que les femmes mais ça change il
ya des ateliers bricolage pour les
femmes y avait ce atelier cuisine pour
les hommes on est entrain de niveler
entrée plat et dessert deux équipes de
cinq personnes se sont affrontées le
temps d'une matinée à l'heure du repas
un jury avait la lourde tâche de
départager femmes et hommes de la soupe
au potiron là je trouvais super
l'idée de mélanger avec de laniscat me
semble très bien il ya un peu trop de
c'est un peu trop relevé je pense pour
moi mais sinon ateliers culinaires
débats expositions la semaine dédiée aux
femmes du monde prévoit une série
d'animations jusqu'au 11 mars
toute cette semaine est fait pour la
convivialité le vivre ensemble et le
fait de se sentir bien les uns avec les
autres pour l'histoire ce sont les
femmes qui ont remporté le concours de
cuisine